- This is Ariana's
first season as a coach.
So what has been the best
thing about coaching so far?
- Other than just getting to know you all
and spend that time and laugh so hard.
I just love seeing the
talent that's on the show
and getting to know these
artists and work with them.
It's just like a really special experience
to be able to share
some of what we've learned-
- [Kelly] Yeah!
- and been able to do in our lives
with these artists
that are just wanting
to do the same thing.
It's a really special opportunity
to be able to share that with people.
To be in that position
is really interesting.
It's just so cool to be there and
- Yeah
- They're all so nice and cool.
I love them. I'm obsessed with my team.
I talk to them all the time.
- Oh my God, your first
team, too. It's like...
You get so upset.
You love them all, but it's so exciting.
- I've broken every rule in my contract.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing) I talk
to them all, all the time.
I'm like DMing them.
They're like, "You're
not supposed to do that."
And I'm like (whispers) "sorry."
Fine.
- No, I know you're sending
stuff to the hotel for them
you're very-
- [Ariana] I know.
This is the coolest
thing about you though.
I really hope people get to see from you.
Like just working with you on the show,
backstage I have to have
my eye makeup re-done,
she's hysterical.
She's so funny. Very quick witted.
I didn't know this about you.
I knew you were talented.
I knew you'd be a great coach.
I knew all those things,
but I didn't know how funny you were
because we'd never really hung much, so.
- This is lifeless. I know.
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] This is lifeless.
- I seem totally, yeah.
- Well, we only see,
- No, I get it.
when we're watching you
we only see performing.
- For sure.
And seven rings, which is like, what?
Who is that? You know?
- Well that's a great song, so.
- Thank you. But like what does that even-
- That's like one of my favorites.
- You know what I mean.
That's not a person, that's...
(kelly laughs)
- She's a robot.
- Punchline. You know what
I mean? It's a punchline.
- No, no, but you're hilarious.
- Thank you.
- And I thought it was so interesting
because usually it takes
coaches that come on,
just being there for eight seasons
it takes them a minute to get used
to being free,
with their words and their personality.
And you kind of like, right-
It was, I think the second
or third day of the blinds.
You were like, "Nevermind, I'm here."
(Ariana laughs)
And it was awesome.
Did you find it nerve-racking?
- It was a little nerve-racking,
but you all made me feel so comfortable
and are the nicest people
that I've met in this whole thing,
just the most fun ever.
And you made me feel so comfortable.
So it's because of you guys.
You guys were push-
and also Blake was
pushing all the buttons.
Sorry. I'll shut up.
- Yes. But you know what though?
- He gotta.
- He does though because he feels able to,
that's when I feel like
it's the best chemistry.
- And it's helpful.
- Yeah it's helpful. It
sets you up for jokes.
- It's helpful.
It does.
(Kelly laughs)
He gives you a good setup every time.
- [Kelly] Yeah. He just opens his mouth.
- Yes. That's it.
He just walks in.
- Well, they act tough.
- He just walks and there's a joke coming.
(Ariana laughs)
But Blake and John,
they are terrified of you, look at this.
- [Ariana] Oh.
- Yes.
- Ariana has a huge fan
base and they are fervent.
And if they show up to vote,
we're all in trouble.
- One hundred percent!
(John laughing)
Are you scared at all?
- Now what?
- [Kelly] Would you even tell us?
I'm not afraid of her fan
base. Where are they at?
Look at me. Where's the camera?
- [John] Bring 'em on.
- Ariana fans, bring it on.
I'm not afraid of Ariana.
- He is so afraid of Ariana's fan base.
(audience laughs)
Thoughts? We said this when you came in,
I mean it was apparent,
literally the entire
audience was screaming.
We were like, "We have no chance."
It was amazing.
- I don't know that that's true.
I really do not think that's true.
I mean-
- But you're a huge star, I don't know-
News flash.
- What are you talking
about Kelly Clarkson?
- What?
(audience laughing)
- No, I'm just saying
it's one those things,
that you watch out.
(audience cheering)
(Kelly laughing)
- No!
- Sorry.
- It's so different.
- [Ariana] Sorry.
- Anyway. It's gotta feel a little good.
Like a little bit of
competitiveness in you
has gotta be like, "They're
all a little terrified."
- I really don't think
that I have the chance you think I have.
- You can think all you want,
but it's true.
(audience laughing)
- First of all. Thank you.
The beautiful thing about it
is that even just being on the show,
this is such a beautiful chance
for them to be seen by
the world in a new way.
This is just us getting to meet them
and give them this first chance
and it's really special.
Cause I think you're gonna
fall in love with all of them.
I really do.
- They're so good. They're so good.